man I can't believe I reached a hundred
thousand subscribers better do something
special for your 100 K sub milestone
subscribe hey man I waited I it's urgent
business Matt I am freaking out all
these people want me to make this big
brand epic video for my big finale and I
don't know what to do
mark what do you want totally not mark
actually dude you're not helping
geez you're just like that's it hey you
know everything there is to know about
Dragon Balls animation right if I say
yes will you leave me alone great I'll
be over in a second
[Applause]
huh hey men how did you you live in
another country the details don't matter
what's important is I'm here we're here
I'm getting back to my roots with the
best animated moments celebrating Dragon
Ball super is last arc and I finally
convinced the anime AJ the guy who knows
everything about Dragon Ball super
xanimation to collab with me on a video
man this is 100k special it's gonna be
awesome
I'm busy why are we making a video I'll
let you put know cute art a wherever you
want best animated moments of the
universe survive vlog let's get underway
now that's the spirit number 10 to top
off our list we have none other than the
man who single-handedly carried the
Future Trunks Ark on his back mister
futoshi Higa Shi de right out of episode
99 we see Crillon and 18 double team
universe full of socha by far the
highlight of this particular episode
Higa she'd a strong effects are on full
display but what made the scene really
stand out was its abundant use of forced
perspective and dynamic posing minor
tracking shot exaggerated gestural
drawing and even some character acting
by schoesser thrown in for good measure
as he dodges Crillon and a teens
ping-pong ball of death I think it
speaks volumes about the standard Dragon
Ball super managed to reach towards the
end of its lifespan considering this is
at the bottom of the list and is already
a strong piece of animation on its own
that's a pretty good sign I mean I
personally thought Nick I chose work
from episode 100 deserve to take this
spot but someone decided to cut it Hey
look dude chill out okay I'll let you
have your way with other entries let me
have this one thing number 9 I think the
best way to describe this entry is
creative and energetic and that is photo
XI hakushi day down to 80
and yes it's higashi day again display
you she talk to you she MS unsightly
touch affecting his character out here
and there this scene is very much a tour
de force of all things he Gucci day is
about the way he executes
larger-than-life movement in a
remarkably grounded fashion is truly
refreshing there's just so much to talk
about in this scene alone my personal
highlight was this expressive intricate
yet measured
movement with Goku that added an air of
finesse to the otherwise dreary rooftop
setting this episode did not need to
look this good but thanks to Fotolia
kashi day it does pack to the brim with
wonderful effects work and non-stop
breakneck action Vitosha hakushi day
demonstrates why he is one of Dragon
Ball super is most talented and valuable
action animators number eight coming out
of seemingly nowhere in episode 96 Kenji
luma and Atsushi Nikaido show up and
deliver a real battle of gods kuriboh
and all one episode removed from the
tournament of powers beginning this
really raised hands expectations for the
action that was to come later in the ark
with delightfully smooth motion
emphasized by seriously interesting
effects Muma section is a sight to
behold
gorgeous plumes of smoke jagged shards
of lightning cutting up the arena floor
there is so much happening on the screen
nakiya then pops in at the end to finish
things off in an equally strong and
impressive fashion with a 3-way beam
clash again interesting shapes and
dynamic effects work this really was an
unexpected treat number 7 wait what I'm
the first one to talk about Tata here
better make this count mm-hmm he's a
animator who needs to realise that
his career choice isn't panning out like
he thought it would his mom was right he
should have gotten that business degree
just kidding I absolutely adore Tata his
work but I think I'd be remiss to
discuss this scene without first drawing
attention to the incredible art
direction which taught to his wonderful
animation has been complemented by here
this cuts animation melds so well with
this episode's board it's impossibly
perfect in the best way on top of that
the lighting in this scene gives off a
warm heavenly quality to it which I
believe works fantastically well with
pates ethereal dreamlike animation so
let's talk about Tata in many ways the
success of this episode is largely down
to today's absurdly long contribution
this is Dragon Ball through-and-through
but with a contemporary tot a twist in
Dragon Ball loop frame action animation
is commonplace and has become bland over
the years yet somehow today manages to
make this interesting to look at with
his
exaggerated poses and intentionally
smeary drawings one passing glance that
taught his work and you'd be forgiven to
think that he might look sloppy but
everything from the stretching limbs
speed lines smears fisheye prospective
shots environment and effects animation
is all masterfully measured to achieve
this magnificently energetic dreamlike
animation we see before us number six
futoshi hakushi days being Dragon Ball
super saving grace for the longest time
in Harriers once again both in the
tournament and on this list delivering
for our viewing pleasure by far his
strongest and most dynamic scene on the
show in episode 116 having not produced
anything for the show in three episodes
he returns in grand fashion animating
Goku sprinting leaping and bounding
across the arena floor as he evades
regroups and scrapes past K fleurs
almost elasticated red blasts all the
while charging his kamehameha jumping
from various chunks of cubic debris this
is the action centric exciting futoshi
Higashi day at the peak of his prowess
however the scene is not over yet
flanked by some of the industry's
brightest stars cannot cyka and can't
iya Koya he wraps the fight up with one
of the arcs most memorable and
jaw-dropping moments I'll let the
visuals speak for themselves
number-5 much like me Yuma and nakaya's
outing in episode 96 only she delivered
a magnificent scene out of seemingly
nowhere to ensure that the first half of
the special was just as special as its
beloved second half wonderful effects
work expressions and subtle use of
squash and stretch is there any wonder
why he's one of Japan's finest as some
of you might know I'm a sucker for
background animation and hoo boy this
has just that I love background
animation not just because it looks dope
but because it adds a valuable sense of
scale and placement for the battle too
often do episodes feel small and
claustrophobic and this episode not only
avoids that but makes this encounter
feel more open and free this cut is
fantastic would have appeared normally
atop any other list and shockingly it's
not even on a she's last entry number
for having animated less than a handful
of cuts for Dragon Ball super Rio honor
she's contribution here is not only
substantial but hugely surprising
springing up in episode 117 he covered
the sequence of events surrounding the
two androids and the giant rib Rianne
it's easy to forget that terrific
animation is not always about crazy
camerawork and extreme movements
especially in a show that says action
centric as Dragonball but subtlety and
realism require just as much if not more
talent to pull off in a convincing
fashion and that's precisely what on the
she brought to the table here River and
slow buildup of momentum as she lurches
forward with a punch to Android 18
perfectly communicates a sense of mass
and size large beings take longer to
move and build up speed and it's
wonderful to see that on display here
even a teen buckling from her force is
another subtle inclusion but adds so
much in conveying how enormous and
imposing grip rihanna is here as a teen
begins making her way up the arm we
greeted with some interesting angles
which are again another component that
adds Sioux River and sense of scale here
there really is so much to talk about
via the incredible effects work
wonderful expressions or the
delightfully smooth running animation
with a hair flip flopping in perfect
harmony this scene just feel so alive
we interrupt this video to bring you the
reason why there isn't more of a video
I'm not gonna beat around the bush as
you know I like to give you guys at
least one video a week to watch and with
how long the runtime of this video was
combined with filming it wasn't possible
to finish or at least in a way that I
was satisfied with now both myself and
AJ had the top three decided and
recorded I just have to put it together
we go into some detail to that top three
is over ten minutes long so you can look
forward to that if you guys want to be
the first ones to get it be sure to
subscribe and to hit that little
notification button down there as well
turns out you too doesn't send videos to
people even if they subscribe so that's
nice but hey I can't be complaining
thank you all for the 100,000
subscribers I cannot begin to tell you
how much that means to me let me know
what you think the top three should be
what your favorite moments for the
tournament of power were I'm genuinely
curious to see if you guys can actually
guess which ones are our top three so
see if you can guess the top three and
the order I'd be very surprised if you
can get that don't forget to rate the
video if you haven't already both myself
and AJ we'll see you guys next week for
the big finale
thank you for your understanding and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you